president Trump back in court as his
chief rival cranks up the heat on the
media to go after him harder a DC
appeals court taking up former president
Trump's claims of absolute immunity from
prosecution in the January 6th case the
former president in court despite not
being required to be there as lawyers
and judges weigh his fate Trump slamming
what he says is an unfair prosecution I
think it's very unfair when a opponent a
political opponent is prosecuted by the
doj by Biden's
doj uh so they're losing in every poll I
think they feel this is the way they're
going to try and win I feel that as a
president you have to have immunity very
simple and As Trump battles it out in
court team Biden thinks it's a political
opportunity the president's campaign
leaders have reportedly been meeting
with members of the media to demand
harsher crit coverage of his rival
Donald Trump according to the report the
campaign feels like Outlets are too
focused on his legal troubles and
haven't paid enough attention to some of
his incendiary recent statements on the
campaign Trail I'm really not sure what
media they read Because I see it
everywhere anyway Michelle Obama also
taking notice of the upcoming election
and is worried about President Trump
winning again I am terrified about what
could possibly happen because our
leaders matter who we select who speaks
for us who holds that bullied pull pit
it affects us in ways that sometimes I
think people take for granted you know
the fact that people think that
government H you know is is it does it
really even do anything and I'm like oh
my God does government do everything for
us and we cannot take this democracy for
granted and sometimes I I worry that we
do all right before we get to any of the
lawyers Jesse does Michelle Obama do
that make you think she's gonna throw
her hat in the ring it does am I gonna
have to come on your show again and say
she's never running it does I don't care
how many people tell me she's not
running that makes me think she might be
okay it might be a convention situation
got it last second what keeps Michelle
up at night peace and prosperity we had
a really great run those four years
Michelle made $100 million bestselling
books they bought two Mansions crime was
low rates were low migration was low I'm
not buying it Biden's flying reporters
to Delaware which is kind of punishment
but flying them to his place in Delaware
to serve them food and alcohol and tell
them don't cover the fact that I'm
trying to throw my political opponent in
prison well probably because every time
he indicts them his numbers go up I just
want you to cover the things he says
like how he wants to be dictator on day
one he wants them to cover the jokes and
the hoaxes don't cover the actions
Donald Trump takes because the actions
are pretty good if you look at the
record I did a deep dive on this law the
Supreme Court please back me up I'm
begging you in 82 the Supreme Court says
the presidents have immunity for what
they do when they take official acts as
president and so if the president's the
chief executive off officer he has the
sole authority to execute and enforce
the law of the land Donald Trump will
just argue that I was uh enforcing
election fraud I was pursuing
allegations of election fraud I was
pursuing recounts I was pursuing
election challenges I was pursuing
alterner slates of electors if you say
that any other president once they leave
office the following president just can
come in with lawyers and indict the
former guy that's crazy that means Joe
Biden can be indicted after he leaves in
a year for child trafficking that means
you can indict Joe Biden for cocaine
possession that means you can indict Joe
Biden for financial fraud it's insane
under this theory that the Democrats are
pushing you could charge AB Lincoln with
murder for prosecuting the Civil War it
it it doesn't make any sense no one's
going to buy it I cannot wait till it
gets to the high court judge do you want
to back him or not back him you did a
good job thank you see yes you're
welcome look here there is an untested
question as to whether or not a
president can be charged with a crime
allegedly occurring during the time that
he was in office we know that presidents
have immunity from lawsuits and civil
cases but this has never been tested
before because no president in American
history has ever been indicted uh uh for
a crime and it does Jesse it opens the
floodgates and when you talk about Biden
talk about a dereliction of Duty 13
servicemen killed in Afghanistan because
they couldn't get an answer as to
whether or not they could engage the
person they thought was and turned out
to be a suicide bomber uh you know maybe
you could indict Obama subject to the
statute of limitations of course for
that drone attack that killed an
American citizen and an Italian citizen
I mean how much do you want to extend
this so the judges know that if they
allow this is the floodgates are open
and every president can be indicted by a
subsequent president now uh if a
president has to look over his shoulder
every time he makes or she makes a
decision it's a nightmare you know that
Dana you've dealt with them I do want to
talk about Michelle Obama though for a
second what I want to talk about is the
fact that she did something that I
didn't think they would come out so soon
and do she tried to Jin up resentment by
blacks against Donald Trump why because
Donald Trump is blacks are moving toward
Donald Trump away from the Democrat
Party Joe Biden is lost what is it 24
percentage points with the blacks and
she says if a similar predicament befell
a black man the bars are different
addressing the fact that uh Trump was
indicted four times and she says um that
that a black man can't be indicted a
bunch of times and run for office you
know she seems to forget that Trump is
not been convicted of anything Trump has
not been found guilty by the Senate
Trump hasn't even uh he's got the
presumption of innocence and she is
trying so hard to remind
African-Americans and to divide which is
what the Democrats do they create
Division and it's racist division you
know a black man couldn't go through
what Donald Trump is going through so
Jesse you're right and I think there's
even more to it Harold it is so good to
have you back around the table and I'll
let you say that too um
since you haven't been here for a few
days would you like to comment on the
case today or what judge Janine was just
talking about good to be back and go
Blue congrats big um two things I I
think I think you're
largely right the thing I struggle with
you just the thing I struggle with is
that the president of the United States
the Supreme Court every judge every
member of Congress uh when I was there
you took an oath of office to defend and
uphold the Constitution and the
Constitution is the greatest legal
document I ever written the greatest
Visionary document uh ever produced by
man about what and how men and women
should treat men and women should treat
one another so I get it I I I struggle
with the absolute immunity argument that
President Trump's lawyers make but I'm
sensitive to what what what the judge
and what Jesse say about do you open a
door uh to endless uh Pursuits by
political
opponents I do think however as I think
about all of that the way I think about
it is if if if you commit a crime um
I don't care who you are our our nation
says We're a nation of laws and no one
is above above the law um in this
particular instance with President Trump
the Nar there's no doubt that the legal
issues here have done nothing but
bolster president Trump's political
fortunes uh and I think what President
Biden's team political team is doing is
what any decent smart political team
would do would try to get the press to
look at the things they think will
Advantage them which is it's what we've
been saying on the show you all in
particular trumpeting for a while is
that the the legal issues and the legal
Pursuits by by democrats or by whomever
have only helped and I would even argue
some Republicans are pursuing and have
only helped president president uh
former president Trump and what they're
now trying to do is get them to focus on
other things judge you mentioned an
interesting point and is it isn't it is
an untested question about what you can
or cannot do with a former president but
but I would say this we've never had a
former president um do what happened on
January 6 and continue to talk about it
in ways that show No Remorse so I'm
going to leave it to the courts and um
again what I hope doesn't happen uh is
what Jesse said in the outset and you
you echoed which is that we whatever we
do we don't lay a predicate or open the
door uh for presidents subsequent
presidents and there will be a woman I
hope in a a sooner time than not he or
she to go after their predecessor
because their predecessor
did something that they may have
disagreed with Greg what about uh
summoning the press and giving them a
spreadsheet of complaint I love that Joe
is angry at the press for not carrying
all the water he's like a terminally
terminally ill man surrounded by dozens
of the top surgeons that are on his
payroll and he's blaming them for the
disease dude they're doing everything
they can to save you they've already
applied 20 coats of paint on this turd
and it's not their fault it still stinks
think about immigration when Trump was
in office the media called The Border C
Crossings a crisis then under Biden when
it's 10 times worse they can they can't
even call it a problem they the media
went all in on white supremacy in the
military which turned out to be another
hoax when it was exposed they released
that report you know right before
Christmas they buried it like it was
Jesse's bald
spot every time every time there's a
jobs report when it comes out they
declared it's the best jobs report ever
and then days later or months later the
revisions come out they inevitably
appear and they bury them like a
dismembered mob snitch they happily
parrot that January 6 is an Insurrection
when we know it wasn't they say crime is
down when it's not and on Q they'll
claim this year was the hottest year
since in 125,000 years they will parot
everything they're supposed to say let's
also remember the things that the media
went for all the hoaxes the fine people
hoax the most easily debunked hoax in
history you just read the transcript no
reporter wanted to do that take whip
gate there was photographic evidence and
testimony that Joe was indeed wrong but
the media went with it anyway there's
obviously the Hunter's laptop story poll
showed that it did help him beat Trump
by suppressing the Scandal which would
have showed a connection between you
know uh what what Hunter was making and
what what maybe Joe was getting then you
look at his declining function which uh
they only cover it if they have no
choice when it just shows up there
meanwhile and you know obviously
Michelle is one of them The Usual
Suspects are predicting the end of the
world if Trump returns and yet when
Trump was President we had peace and
prosperity no Wars the only thing Trump
broke was the media's minds and that's
what we're dealing with right now we're
dealing with a massive nervous breakdown
that's been going on for almost four
years actually it started earlier and
it's just going to get worse you got to
get used to this there's going to be so
much crap flying I mean he's already
Hitler I don't know what they're going
to do next you know what's worse than
Hitler yeah where do you go from there
killme that's all po Brian right Ione
Brian killme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on you YouTube so subscribe
right now